i was looking at various polls and saw
that you're
one of the most disliked tech leaders
today
54 unfavorable rating
elon musk is 23 it's basically everybody
has a very high unfavorable rating that
are tech leaders
maybe you can help me understand that
why do you think so many people dislike
you
some even hate you
and how do you regain their trust and
support given everything you just said
why are you losing the battle
in
explaining to people what actual impact
social media has in society
well
i'm curious if that's a u.s survey or
world it is u.s yeah so i think that
there's a few dynamics one is that
our brand
has been
somewhat uniquely challenged in the u.s
compared to other places it's not that
there are i mean other countries we have
issues too but i think in the u.s there
was
this dynamic where
if you look at like the next sentiment
of of kind of coverage or or attitude
towards us you know before 2016 i think
that there were probably very few months
if any where it was negative and since
2016 i think they're probably very few
months if any then it's been positive
politics so but i think it's it's a
specific thing and this is very
different from other places so i think
in a lot of other countries in the world
um you know the sentiment towards meta
and our services is is extremely
positive um in the us we have more
challenges and i think compared to other
companies
um
you can look at
certain industries
i think if you look at it from like a
partisan perspective um not not from
like a political perspective but just
kind of culturally it's like there are
people who are probably more left of
center and there are people more right
of center and there's you know kind of
blue america and red america there are
certain industries that i think maybe
one
half of the country has a more positive
view towards than another and i think
we're in a
um
one of the positions that we're in that
i think is is really challenging is that
because of a lot of the content
decisions that we're that we've
basically had to arbitrate
um
and because we're not a partisan company
right we're not we're not a democrat
company or a republican company we're
trying to make the best decisions we can
to help people connect and um and help
people have as much voice as they can
while you know having some rules because
it we're running a community
um
the net effect of that is that we're
kind of constantly making decisions that
piss off people in both camps um
and
the effect that i've sort of seen
is that when we make a decision
that is
that's a controversial one that's gonna
upset
say about half the country
um
those decisions are all negative some um
from a brand perspective because it's
not like like if we make that decision
in one way and you know say half the
country is happy about that particular
decision that we make they tend to not
say oh sweet meta got that one right
they're just like ah you didn't mess
that one up right but their opinion
doesn't tend to go up by that much
whereas the people who who kind of are
on the other side of it um are like god
how could you mess that up like how
could you possibly think that like that
piece of content is okay and should be
up and should not be censored or um and
so i think
the where whereas if okay if you leave
it up and
um
you know it's or if you take it down the
people who thought it should be taken
down or you know it's like all right
fine great you didn't mess that one up
so our internal assessment of
the kind of analytics on our brand are
basically any time one of these big
controversial things comes up in society
um
our brand goes down with half of the
country and then like if you and then if
you just kind of extrapolate that out
it's just been very challenging for us
to try to navigate what is a polarizing
country in a principled way where we're
not trying to kind of hew to one side or
the other we're trying to do what we
think is the right thing but i mean
that's what i think is the right thing
for us to do though so i mean that's
that's what we'll we'll try to keep
doing just as a human being how does it
feel though when you're giving so much
of your day-to-day life to try to
heal division to try to do good in the
world as we've talked about
that so many people in the u.s the place
you call home
have a negative view of you as a leader
as a human being and
the company you love
well i mean it's not great um but
but i
i mean look if i wanted people to think
positively about me as a person
um
i don't know i'm not sure if you go
build a company i mean it's like like
our social media company i mean it's
exceptionally difficult to do with the
social media yeah so
i mean i don't know there is a
dynamic
where a lot of the other people running
these companies internet companies have
sort of stepped back
and they just do things that are sort of
i don't know less controversial and
um and some of it may be that they just
get tired over time but you know it's um
so i don't know i i i think that you
know running a company is hard building
something at scale is hard you only
really do it for a long period of time
if you really care about what you're
doing
um and
yeah so i mean it's not great but like
but look i i think that at some level
whether
25 of people dislike you or
75 percent of people dislike you your
experience as a public figure is going
to be that there's a lot of people who
dislike you right so um yeah so i i
actually am not sure how different it is
um you know certainly you know we've
the country's gotten more polarized and
and we in particular have gotten you
know more controversial over the last
five or years or so but um
but
i don't know i kind of think like as a
public figure and leader of one of these
enterprises come to the job part of yeah
part of what you do is like and and look
you can't just the answer can't just be
ignore it right because
like a huge part of the job is like you
need to be getting feedback and
internalizing feedback on how you can do
better but i think increasingly what you
need to do is be able to figure out you
know who are the
the kind of good faith critics who are
criticizing you because
they're trying to help you do a better
job rather than tear you down and those
are the people who i just think you have
to cherish and like and and and listen
very closely to the things that they're
saying because you know i think it's
just as dangerous to tune out everyone
who says anything negative um and just
listen to the people who who are kind of
positive and support you you know as it
would be psychologically to pay
attention trying to make people who are
never going to like you like you um so i
think that that's that's just kind of a
dance that that people have to do but
but i mean i you know you kind of
develop more of a feel for like who
actually is trying to accomplish the
same types of things in the world and
who has different ideas about how to do
that and how can i learn from those
people and like yeah we get stuff wrong
and when the people whose opinions i
respect call me out on getting stuff
wrong
that that hurts and makes me want to do
better but i think at this point i'm
pretty tuned to just all right if
someone if i know they're they're kind
of like operating in bad faith and
they're not really trying to help um
then you know i don't know it's not it's
it doesn't you know i think over time it
just doesn't bother you that much
you